I must not fear fear is the mind killer
fear is the little death that brings
total obliteration I will face my fear I
will permit it to pass over me and
through me and when it has gone past I
will turn the inner eye to see its path
where the fear has gone there will be
nothing only I will remain
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
in Frank Herbert's 1960 science fiction
novel dune the all-female Vinny Jesuits
are among the most formidable and
cunning in all the inhabited universe
the Benning Jesuit rose to power in the
political turmoil that followed the but
Larian jihad the event which outlawed
Thinking Machines in all the universe
they quickly established themselves as
an influential political force
distinguished among the men in Jesuit
are they even more powerful Reverend
mothers of any Jesuit ascends to the
level of Reverend Mother only when she
undergoes the spiced agony by consuming
the water of life the deadly substance
excreted by drowning sandworm the bene
Jesuit sister can through use of
internal organic chemical control
convert the substance rendering it
harmless and allowing her to experience
its Hallucigenia effects by surviving
the spiced agony the bene Jesuit has
unblocked her genetic memory now able to
look back through the eons of the lives
of her female ancestors and share in
their experience the lives of their male
ancestors are hidden from them it is a
place where no woman can look for it is
terrifying to them but still the binning
Jesuit desired knowledge of this hidden
plane in order to unlock the male half
of their genetic memory they have
devised a breeding program which has
gone on for thousands of generations the
goal to produce the male Benin Jesuit he
would be able to look where they could
not he would be the key sent a direct
the one who could be in many places at
once the one with perfect memory through
intense ritual the bene Jesuit have
learned to break through the barriers of
the mind by engaging in the prana Bindu
the bene Jesuit can control every aspect
of their physiology which gives a many
abilities such as neutralizing poison by
honing in on certain chemicals in their
bodies and altering them though it is
forbidden the been ages or it can even
slow their aging drastically through
intense physiological control their
martial arts known as the weirding way
for great mental
physical control allows them to move in
ways that seem too fast for the human
eye to perceive making them highly
formidable in combat certain lineages
are truth singers through close
observation of small physiological
changes in others they can accurately
assess whether or not a person speaks
truth and read their mental and
emotional states in ways that seem like
telepathy to common people through great
alignment of the mind and body the many
Jesuit are able to perceive their senses
and much more profound and exact ways
than mere mortals are capable of one of
the greatest and most disquieting
abilities of any Jesuit is the voice
through use of the voice the bene Jesuit
can assess the mental state of a person
and program them through subtle cues and
nuances of speech to respond in a way
that suits her intentions through voice
of any desert and control the actions of
another person to an extraordinary
almost supernatural level though the
abilities of the bene Jesuit appear
supernatural to the common people of the
universe they are not their abilities
are the result of careful honing of
human potential over thousands of years
the misión era protect Eva which is
referred to as the Binion Jesuit
Sisterhood's black arm of superstition
is responsible for sowing the seeds of
superstition in primitive cultures such
as the Fremen culture of the planet dune
they did this so that The Sisterhood
could take advantage of said cultures
when those seeds of superstition grew
into full-fledged legends the venon
Jesuits sister could use these legends
to later cast herself as a guide
protector or some other figure in
fulfillment of a prophecy in order to
manipulate the religious subjects for
protection or other purposes the misión
era protect Eva is also key in preparing
the Empire for the arrival of the key
sets had Iraq who would be viewed as a
religious figure for their abilities and
religious Association the bene Jesuits
are employed throughout the universe
this makes them extremely important on a
grand level and also very dangerous
at the start of doom even the Emperor
Shaddam Kirino the fourth takes counsel
from the Reverend Mother Gaius Mohan
although that any Jesuit are spread
through the vastness of space they
remain fiercely loyal to the sisterhood
and its agendas while men do maintain
some important roles for the vini Jesuit
they and all the females of the
sisterhood are subject to one woman the
Mother Superior
she alone maintains absolute control of
the sisterhood and their loyalty to her
is almost unquestioned for thousands of
years with any Jesuit sisterhood chose
to exercise its power by acting only in
the background of Imperial politics but
this all changed during the events of
doomed after they discovered that their
own Lady Jessica had defied them by
producing a son and training him in the
ways of the many Jesuit could this whole
Atreides be the key sets had rack come
at last
you